he's the cheater in Chief Joe Biden
caught red-handed with a note card that
appears to include a reporter's question
right before he called on her how
convenient Biden holding his first news
conference after announcing he is
running for re-election and it turns out
what was on Joe's card was indeed very
similar to the question he got asked the
White House says it's no big deal yet
couldn't explain why he needed it in the
first place it is entirely normal for a
president to be briefed on reporters who
will be asking questions at a press
conference and issues that we expect
they might ask about do not have
specific questions in advance that's not
something that we do and in fact I would
point out the questions that was asked
was different than what was on the card
that you all saw
but I guess he couldn't get a cheat
sheet for this moment Biden actually got
thrown off by a couple of youngsters on
take your child to work day
where are you where are you um grand
Sunday or granddaughters yeah God one in
New York
two in Philadelphia
there's a three you know three because I
got one granddaughter who is
I don't know the last country I've
traveled I'm thinking once for the last
one I was in I
um I was I mean yeah you're right
Ireland that sure was oh and while Joe
runs for cover from the friendly media
his Challengers are lining up check out
this new Fox News poll RFK Jr and
Marianne Williamson combined have nearly
30 percent of Democratic primary voters
but Wolfies says Democrats need to get
behind Biden because quote we're trying
to save democracy
the person to do the job is doing the
job you get behind him and we won't have
a problem the minute you start making
inroads or maybe this person or maybe
this person we're we're done for so make
a decision make a decision he's done a
lot for the country and he runs back
from the precipice maybe you it's not a
perfect country but it's better than
where we were
okay I'll start with you Katie shouldn't
the president of the United States be
able to go out and answer questions
without a cheat sheet and with questions
on it and I'm not talking about bullet
points which aren't unusual I'm talking
about specific questions an uncommon
level of specificity in fact well first
the response to Whoopi I mean it's
amazing to the side of the political
aisle who screams about protecting
democracy isn't interested in having a
simple debate and if Joe Biden's record
is so good why not have him out there to
defend his record and to talk to the
American people and to reassure
Democrats who are concerned about him
running that he can handle the job but
this is embarrassing I think more for
the media because they're allowing the
administration to push them around the
White House correspondence association
should have more expectations than than
this and the fact is that the president
shows through these cards that he's not
the one who is really in charge it's the
people who are writing the answers on
these car cards for him he's not giving
orders he's taking orders and I think
there's big questions about that given
he wants to run for your election and
he's supposed to be the guy who's
elected and in charge rather than
bureaucrats who he hires to make
decisions to talk about these big policy
positions but in terms of the media and
I covered the Trump Administration and
was in the White House a lot and I got
moved once from a press conference from
the back of the room to the front of the
room and I was called on and that was
like a big mainstream media Scandal that
they had moved me to the front of the
room so somehow there may be some kind
of collusion there was none and this
happens and the White House in the L.A
times are on the same page saying
we didn't talk about it but we do talk
about topics the topics are pretty damn
close to the question you know Greg this
is the first press conference the
president has had and what 178 days or
something and the first one after he
announced for re-election and the issue
of age in his cognitive level uh came up
and he just said watch me well we did
watch him and it appears that the
president was unable to answer questions
after a meeting with the president of
South Korea where issues were discussed
like microchips and so you say to
yourself if he needs a card to answer
the Press who is doing the negotiating
with the president of South Korea did he
have those note cards in those meetings
and negotiations who is running it well
that's the Eternal question I mean this
guy's so old he better not renew his
library card
gets upset around green bananas think
about this though when it came to like
Donald Trump the Press was relentless
they peppered him with endless gotcha
questions they tried to trap him they
tried to humiliate him and he still came
at them at every moment and here you
have the Press get basically give this
old fool a take-home test of what
amounts to an answer key and what's that
say as usual they will always be in the
back for the Democrats and they know
that the guy they support is Hall is a
hollow mess and needs all the help that
he can get and I don't blame Joe for
pushing for these perks but I do wonder
if the Press has to weigh a decision
it's like if I'm going to get face time
I better say yes to supplying the
questions because if I don't Supply the
question I won't be able to ask the
question so instead I'll just play along
and maybe you know I'll get a promotion
but here's a great question for America
do you really think you should vote for
a candidate that the view endorses the
view have you seen the view it's
basically a shrinks waiting room in hell
if Joe if Joy not apologizing for some
bigoted remark Whoopi's apologizing for
some bigoted remark meanwhile they
indulge in Karen politics right it's
like the bitter unmarried white cat lady
who you know stupidly gave Oliver money
to a BLM GoFundMe page they're naive
they're stupid uh whippy says we're
better off now what metrics is she using
is she talking about inflation or war or
crime or immigration I think what she's
talking about is her own emotional
well-being like this is what it's about
it's like hey at least we don't have
Trump's tweets anymore the country's
screwed but you know I don't wake up in
the middle of the night and wonder what
mean thing Donald Trump is going to say
I would take the Mean Tweets any day
over the state of this country and it's
selfishness on the media's part that
they don't realize that well yeah they
and you know what even if they did they
wouldn't change their behavior in any
event because it's the same ideology
ideology but Joey I want you to listen
to something that van Jones said
she is in such an unusual position she's
a woman she's black she's Asian and
she's running alongside the oldest
person to ever do it so she's
essentially running for president that's
what she's doing and I think people
understand that but I think she
understands that and I think and I think
that she's going to rise to the occasion
I won't even go to the rise to the
occasion part of it but the idea that
van Jones who's a Democrat is like it
doesn't really matter what Biden is
doing
um and she's running and again I guess
they have to support her I think that
probably scares the Democrats that are
kind of in charge of Biden more than
anything is the idea that they may have
to wake up one day and she's the boss
and she may not be the kind of herded
sheep that Biden seems to be I mean the
only thing I know that Biden has pushed
back on from those that are kind of
pulling the strings or maybe the
progressive left two different groups
there those in the White House and the
really loud progressives is maybe
domestic policy may be something like
Afghanistan like where he didn't listen
to the generals and all the advisors and
kind of stuck to his guns there and you
know when you look at like his
granddaughter that he doesn't
acknowledge it you can understand if you
can leave a little girl hung out to dry
it's pretty easy to leave a few thousand
Marines hung out to dry if you don't if
you can't be there for the most
vulnerable within our society how would
you be there for for those that are
armed and trained to to at least take
care of themselves so that's the
category I put Joe Biden in that's where
he is he is answering to people that are
on his shoulders and guiding him this
direction got that includes the Easter
Bunny probably includes Kamala I would
venture to say she's probably a lot
smarter behind the scenes than she shows
herself to be because I saw her up on
the diastere in those Senate
confirmation hearings where she had
preparation and she came out like a
bulldog on attack and that is not what
we've gotten from her as vice president
and with someone like sleepy Joe that's
what you would expect and probably want
okay
um you know what Jessica you saw Joe
Biden he he was like counting his
grandchildren I suspect he had a problem
because there's one that the bidens
don't recognize Hunter's child with a
stripper and also the last country that
he was at even he didn't remember where
he was so when Marianne Williamson you
know slams a DNC for not holding primary
debates you know is she indirectly
saying Joe can't handle it and that's
why they're not doing it I don't think
she's saying he can't handle it I think
that she's saying that we should have a
democratic debate about this and that I
deserve to be on the stage as much as
anyone and that it should be a choice
that's what democracy right
so I think and I've been consistent
about this I think he should do more
press conferences I think he should do
debates I think that he does better than
people can yes I do think that he can't
I I really do and I'm I'm not just
saying that because I get paid to sit
here I'm saying that because I actually
think it so it's great that those two
things come together
um I think that he does well his off the
cuff moments got him huge pull bumps in
the Democratic primary remember every
time they kind of talked out of turn
people were like that's the Joe Biden
that we know and if he is a complete
disaster then we deserve to know that as
well but I will say that the criticism
of this that's being lobbed at the DNC I
did not hear lobbed at the RNC when they
endorsed president Trump undivided
support in February of 2019 there were
three other candidates Bill weld Mark
Sanford and Joe Walsh and I'm not saying
that they were getting tons of support
but those people were in the race and
they were not given the chance to debate
him States turned to winner take all
they didn't even allow them to vote on
these other possibilities so come come
on let's be a little bit fair about
incredible those are even close to RFK
Junior well first of all let's see how
well our walls I mean nobody even knows
I'm talking about he's at 19 percent
that was last week on a video okay a
let's see where RFK Jr is in in a little
bit right let's give them a moment he's
a Kennedy it's flashy he has Cheryl
Hines I'd love to have Cheryl Hines by
my side on this but it democracy is
about principles and if the principle is
that there should be debates then you
should have thought that there should
have been debates I think there should
be debates in the the Republicans well
I'm gonna coming up now I think everyone
should debate I think the American
people deserves
I doubt and we can if we get the tapes
we can roll them I doubt that as many
Republicans were as vociferous in their
systems
primary debates for the Republicans I
mean I just remember 17 on the state no
2016 I'm talking about 2020 for real
well of course in 2016 yeah there it was
an open Obama couldn't run again but I'm
talking about re-election all right well
I have a feeling he can't do it because
he can't tell you how many grandchildren
yeah it was last week I'm sorry Trump
held cards that said I I hear you what
would you you like me to know about your
experience talking to Parkland families
that seems like you should be able to
get that right hi winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now